rosenfeld is israel's police national
spokesman to foreign media joins us now
from west jerusalem good to have you
with us so the latest tension started
with
fears concern that israeli police
might uphold an israeli court order and
forcibly evict palestinians from
neighborhood as well as
actions administrative and security
measures taken by
israel in east jerusalem around the
al-aqsa mosque compound my question to
you though so do you accept that you are
an
occupying power which the this is
according to the un you are an occupying
power which has no legal authority
to impose israeli law in these occupied
territories
uh israel and the country that we live
in is a country that belongs to the
jewish people
with the history of thousands of years
back
israel and the different units and i'm
referring to the idf and the israeli
national police will do everything
possible in order to maintain public
order
and prevent large-scale incidents from
taking place
in jerusalem if we look back just last
year when we were dealing here in israel
with kovid19 ramadan was very peaceful
and very calm and quiet last year okay
over the last two with me but but then
what you're telling
viewers is people like the official
spokesperson rupert colville for the un
office
of the high commissioner for refugees
when he said on may the 7th
2021 and i quote
given the disturbing scenes in sheikh
jarrah over the past few days
we wish to emphasize that east jerusalem
remains part of the occupied palestinian
territory
in which international humanitarian law
applies
and the occupying power must respect
unless
absolutely prevented the laws in the
force in the country you're saying
to viewers that in fact he's wrong
because as you said
this is your country you don't recognize
that you're an occupation
what i'm saying is we're not an occupied
force this country belongs to israel is
israel is a strong unique and
humanitarian country at the moment
you've taken out of proportion the
israeli arabs unfortunately with inside
jerusalem
have taken out of proportion a dispute
about sheikh
there are many disputes that take place
in many different areas but they can be
solved
by the israeli courts whatever the
israeli courts will decide
will be accepted both by the jewish
families that live there as well as by
the israeli-palestinian families that
live there as well
i'm going back to the point that we made
which what happened just two weeks ago
on the temple mount
thousands of palestinians arrived there
and instead of celebrating
they gathered rocks and stones and
attacked our police officers and jewish
worshipers at the western war that is
something that is unacceptable
as a response our police units went
inside the temple mount area
only used non-lethal weapons and
dispersed that riot
that is something that we've dealt with
many times you have
jumped in many times if you let me jump
in but unesco
says on point five of its may the second
2017 ruling that quote
legislative and administrative measures
and actions taken by israel
the occupying power
it says are especially says in
particular quote the basic law in
jerusalem are null and void
and must be rescinded forth with do you
recognize
that it's because of your interventions
in the the al-aqsa mosque compound in
east jerusalem
that is provoking the reaction from the
palestinians or complaining about
do you recognize that
i have to confirm and make it clear to
your viewers as well
the issue of the temple mount the temple
mount the status quo will be
kept and held and will continue
by israel this quarter so thank you so
much my question is
is unesco wrong in saying that you
your attempts to enforce the basic law
in jerusalem intervene
in as you call it temple mountain
palestinians call it the al-aqsa mosque
compound a null and void
do you recognize that yes or no my
answer
i will answer you and my answer is is
that the israeli national police and the
israeli government
is making sure that the status quo on
the temple mount will continue
this is one of the issues that we're
dealing with people are praying on the
temple mount and i'm talking about
muslims five times a day in peace and
quiet in a respectable manner so you're
not really
asking answering the question about
whether you recognize what u.n
organizations are saying let me quote to
you then instead what human rights
watchers said in its report
of june 4 2017 israeli authorities
have since 1967 facilitated the transfer
of civilians to the
occupied west bank do you accept what
u.n
organizations what human rights
organizations are saying
you are an occupying power that is
violating international law
i can see that you've uh gathered and
put together all the quotes
the point is is you and people have to
understand and realize you're not
talking and interviewing me
in 1967. we're talking about 2021 21.
sir to your question for colville in may
the 7th 2021 and i have done my research
and i make no apology for it
these need to be addressed that's okay i
understand that are you
saying to viewers the un unesco
uh amnesty international i've got a
quote here if you want to hear it
where they where they say settling
civilians in occupied territories
violates international humanitarian law
and amounts to a war crime are you
telling viewers the un
the international court of justice
amnesty international human rights watch
are
all wrong and only you are right i'm
saying
no what i'm saying is is that jerusalem
so you said no if they're not wrong
then you admit that you are an occupying
power that is violating international
law by your interventions
i heard your question and i will answer
your question now
israel is in charge and is responsible
and is making decisions as to what takes
place here in jerusalem both west
and east jerusalem together in the
different neighborhoods and the
different areas
israel is fully in control of dealing
with everything
in terms of security israel is
protecting
the israeli jewish citizens as well as
israeli arabs who are living in the
different areas and the neighborhoods
our responsibility is also to protect
to make sure that there are no frictions
between the different size the different
communities
i'm going back to a very important point
which is a sensitive point
which is what happened on the temple
mount we saw thousands of palestinians
taking the law into their own hands and
attacking officers
and attacking other areas that is
something that is unacceptable
and the israeli police officers right in
and around who are guarding the three
most holiest sites
the temple mount the western wall and
the church of
the sepulcher are making sure that we're
doing everything to prevent
large-scale incidents right
what you're doing i don't think you've
really addressed the point
and the question i've put you of whether
you recognize what these organizations
are saying that what you're
what you're doing is taking the law into
your own hands but i'm afraid
we are out of time thank you very much
for explaining your perspective we'll
leave it to the viewers to draw their
conclusions
thank you